christmas is a time to spend at home
with loved ones of course but for some
of the valley's most vulnerable
that just isn't possible and that's why
one local non-profit is working to help
homeless moms get back on their feet
lorco mana has more we ask
you bless this food that we're about to
receive saying grace ahead of a
christmas feast
this food is a blessing for these
mothers and their children who have
nowhere else to go this holiday
they're residents of living grace homes
a nonprofit in henderson that provide
shelter for homeless women
ages 14 to 24 who are pregnant or have
young kids
i'm very grateful for being here katelyn
shaw is a mother of three
her youngest son just two months old as
a new arrival this dinner is more than
just a meal
this will be my first christmas
where i wasn't alone even with having my
kids
it still feels lonely i got a pair of
jeans
kaitlyn and the handful of other moms
here even getting christmas gifts this
week
some for the first time living grace
means a lot especially at these times
because if it wasn't for living grace i
wouldn't be able to spend the holidays
with my kids
since 2007 living grace homes has
assisted more than 500 young mothers
with education
and employment if we can help them
either get that diploma
or their ged that puts them in a better
position
to be able to get a job that will
support them and their children but jobs
and low income housing are scarce right
now due to the coronavirus
that makes it more difficult despite the
challenges created by covid19
living grace homes is staying positive
and has a christmas wish for the new
year
i hope to see the the state open up more
so that people can go back to work and
our young ladies can find jobs
mac and cheese but for now a little
christmas cheer goes a long way
turning this house into a home it feels
like kind of like a family and i'm
something i've never really had before
orco mana 8 news now